صحيح صحيح يعني انت بتعرف يا صديقي العزيز
ان الخارطه
السياسيه والخريطه المجتمعيه للمنطقه
اصابها تغيرات كانت تصادمه انا لم اصل
مرحله الياس هناك فرق بين كيف تقرا الواقع
كيف تقرا
ولا بد من التميز بين الياس والاحباط
الياس من اعلى واوضح عناوينه وعدم الانجاز
لا انا خلال سنوات الحرب استطيع ان اقول
لك ان كان ان انجازي كان كثيفا جدا سواء
في السينما او في الادب او في المسرعه
وكنت اقلهم في التلفزيون لم انجز سوى ثلاث
مسلسلات عبر عشر سنوات لكن احنا بالحاله
الثقافيه العامه للاسف هلا اصبحت الدراما
التلفزيونيه هي مرجعيه حضورك يعني عندما
تغيب عن الدراما التلفزيونيه يفتقده الناس
يبدو لانها اكثر الوسائل تاثيرا والشيوعا
وانتشارا بس انا خلال هذه السنوات انجزت
حوالي ثمن افلام روائيه خمسه منها كممثل
وثلاث منا كمخرج
وانجزت حوالي ثمان مسرحيات ايضا
وخمس مجموعات همم ادبيه بين القصه وبين
السير الذاتيه لا انا عبرت عما اصابني من
هذه الحرب كل هذه الالام انا رميتها على
اوراق احيانا او على شريط سينمائي حاولت
ان اقول ما احسست به حاولت ان اؤثر ما
مررنا به لانه باعتبر واحد من اردوان
الرئيسيه ان نكون موثقين بلحظه من لحظات
لهذه الذاكره كي عندما تاتي الاجيال تعرف
عبر عمل فني وليس عبر القراءات سياسيه
اصطفافيه عبر عمل فني على مسافه واحده من
الاشياء يمكن لها ان تقرا همم احساس الناس
في تلك
يعني في المجال الذي نهتم به عملته بهذا
الحي الطويلا وبالتالي هذا سبب لي غياب عن
الدراما التلفزيونيه سنوات طويله كان في
شعور بقليل من الله ما بسميه من الاحباط
لكن لم يصل الحدود عدم الانجاز يعني ضلينا
عم نشتغل
وتعرضنا ايضا جيلنا من الفنانين لبعض
العسف